vo Brendon what up Zack Barrett from New
Jersey here got a king under sting at
for you a Valentine's Day coming up made
a reservation for me and my girl at
White Castle sounds a little weird a lot
of people are doing it these past couple
years reservation was pretty hard to get
King at our sting it Gang Gang buzz buzz
gang is that oh that fast I mean it's
definitely I think it's unique sometimes
oh here we go and here's an image right
there did you know it's like it's a
thing they do like candlelit dinners at
White Castle on Valentine well that's
kind of fun I love that oh I don't know
that's fast food it was kind of fun it's
different
says the guy who planned nothing for his
girl $4.99 right first of all rose oil
roses in a vase what do you think here I
mean dude I look I hope it gets nice I
think it's a great marketing idea it
looks fun it's cute your girl won't
expect if she thinks you're just going
she's gonna be depressed but she walks
in the door they got a nice tablecloth
she's still gonna be she's still gonna
be a little depressed you're just out
White Castle I'm sorry I'm not huge
White Castle fan on you I'd be down with
Fitz's Taco Bell I like a manageable
sandwich man yeah I like Taco Bell dude
really put a nice gordita or that
freakin nacho supreme with a girl yeah
I'm with [ __ ] your pants there's nothing
better you must be married that sounds
like something coming from a married guy
but hey let's go vote use different
toilets in the house oh man
it's basically playing Russian roulette
in your pants dude we talk about your
race home dude start living bro you're
right start living a little Doug you're
right I gotta you know don't not get to
try it man yeah she's an idea though
this is better than all these [ __ ] are
doing he don't have an idea
we should bring her to my show because
I'm giving free tickets you're ten
you're gonna Hotel you probably work at
yes you don't have nothing has on the
typical Asian athletic injury with the
carpal tunnel it is a carpal tunnel
that's the asian ACL they call it carpal
tunnel for typing on a computer come on
bro
thankfully nobody chin yeah I asked him
if you had I thought he's going
rollerblading
I thought your raise it like a really
strong verb like what here haraki's is
getting big yes I thought you pull it up
though Cheney forgetting do it do it on
both man I got a bigger one coming in
hell yeah it's that bad it's pretty bad
here dude nothing just bad as Nick is
sprouting bird out of his back look at
these two I think we're in the upside
down bro Kat and Derek have the
coronavirus nice to have fallen apart I
think I got the carpal tunnel too like
literally cannot feel my index finger if
I squeeze my shoulder it my thumb goes
numb too here we go hey this is your
guys way of asking for a raise didn't
work quit this [ __ ] act yet going on
dude we're in the upside down man
that's where we are Chin's dressed like
a redneck hey Nick is turn it into a
toucan this is the widest culture we're
looking for her I said we need a Mexican
female
even our text he's like we need Craig
bro Mike you're the worst
[Music]